we've always dreamed of infusing our
bodies with technology sure there are
opportunities to heal ourselves but we
can also improve our vision strengthen
our bones and we're even getting pretty
good at replacing lost limbs thing is
there's a problem electronics and body
fluids do not mix the environment within
your body is actually quite corrosive to
the kinds of materials that you normally
have in your iPhone or something like
that but what if electronics behaved
less like metal and more like the
materials that make up our bodies in a
basement lab of MIT a team of
researchers has the answer
most electronics we interact with are
dry and hard
unlike the inside of the human body but
this synthetic material is somewhere in
between those two it's called a hydrogel
what is a hydrogel a hydrogel is a
polymer network infiltrated with lots of
water
for example jell-o's we eat hydrogen's
right if you look at a composition of
the body who body accepted teeth boom
and a nail all other parts they are
hydrogen we are hydrogels we hydros
actually the majority of human body are
hydros Schwinn has hydrogels while
synthetic are biocompatible able to
exist within the body without any
adverse reaction his goal is to encase
electronics like these sensors inside
the gel which can then be implanted in
the body this isn't a new idea but it's
never worked before because of the
properties of traditional hydro gels so
just want to show you kind of like some
of the materials right so what's
interesting what are jealous is this is
like typical gels are like this try to
stretch this so that's kind of like a
typical job you try to stretch it and it
breaks really easily right now try
stretching this one it's like I'm making
noodles but that was pretty far yeah
that's a good thing this is very
reliable very stretchy okay I'll stop
breaking it through this new hydrogel
has another benefit it's sticky
so sticky that adhesion tests show a
bond between the gel and a metal plate
is stronger than the bond between
tendons and bone this stickiness is the
breakthrough researchers have been
looking for electronics bond to the gel
but the gel stitches with the body to
demonstrate a simple use of the gel
schwinn hood developed a prototype for a
smart bandage so this is like a super
band-aid yes that would deliver medicine
right that's correct so the idea is that
this will sense something either
temperature chemicals or if you have an
infection antibiotic so if I need an
antibiotic what might that look like so
for example you see it flowing I see the
coming in and then over time that
medicine would diffuse them correct on
demand yes only one needed correct
biocompatible electronics conjure
futuristic images but one of the most
immediate and important functions is
simply health monitoring placing sensors
in our bodies that can collect data on
what makes us healthy and what doesn't
a lot of these technologies are going to
be employed in chronic diseases that
affect millions of people
everything from cardiovascular disease
type 2 diabetes is schizophrenia to
depression these technologies are going
to be part of our future because chronic
disease is not going away looking
forward what do you see as the timeline
for your work making its way into
people's bodies how far off are good
question we need a locater fda approval
so still it will take some time probably
on the order of a few years we've long
known that
bollocks in the body could help improve
and extend human life
this hydrogel is an important first step
in that direction it will not in and of
itself cure a disease or fix a defect
but it could be a building block of the
medicine of the future